(shushing)
(baby babbling)
- I don't know why she won't sleep.
I mean, she's fed, she's
got a fresh diaper,
she's swaddled.
- Maybe it's 'cause
we're making eye contact.
- What?
- Well, I read that if
you make eye contact,
it keeps them engaged and awake.
(baby cooing)
Is she asleep?
- I don't know, I can't see her.
What is that?
- This is a glove full of beans.
You lay it on their back and it,
you know, makes it feel like someone's
touching them while they're sleeping.
- Okay, where did you hear about that?
And don't say.
- [In unison] The internet.
- Right.
Let's get out of here.
(blow dryer blowing)
(vacuum cleaner roaring)
(dryer running)
♫ There was a farmer who had a dog
♫ And Bingo was his name-o
♫ Arf I-N-G-O
♫ There was a farmer who had a dog
♫ And Bingo was his name-o
♫ Arf arf arf-o
♫ There was a farmer who had a dog
♫ And Bingo was his name-o
♫ B-I-N-G-O ♫
(car body squeaking)
- [Father] Is she asleep yet?
- [Mother] Nope.
- [Father] How 'bout now?
- [Mother] No.
- [Father] Now?
I don't get it.
I mean, I guess, let's
just let her stay up.
- No.
I think I have one last thing.
- What are you doing?
- I read that if you do this,
that they will asleep
in less than a minute.
- Okay, we're trying to
get her to go asleep,
not tease her like a southern belle.
I stand corrected.
(door creaking)
(baby cooing)
(frustrated sighing)
- That's our bad.
- Yeah.
Our bad.
♫ There was a farmer who had a dog
♫ And Bingo was his name-o
♫ B-I-N-G-O ♫